I've always said that whatever I put in
my mouth is my business
[Music]
hello my name is Scott Jones I am the
executive chef at crossroads kitchen Los
Angeles California I started the
plant-based restaurant with Chrissie
Hynde in Akron Ohio called the
vegetarian and that's when I got into
the plant-based cooking world today
they're trying the impossible burger
chicken and waffles the crispy chicken
Milanese sandwich and our kale Caesar
okay I'm so excited so excited it
literally just looks like ground beef my
love for cheeseburgers is
well-documented and I eat these
endlessly it's a really good salad kale
especially when its raw like this is
hard to make tastes good but this tastes
really good yeah I would have no idea
there's no dairy and not dressing I
couldn't eat this every day for the rest
of my life I'd be like
[Music]
just take a chicken sandwich only my
family's from Argentina we make Nealon
SS it tastes like that reminds me of
like going to like a deli and staying
like a nice fresh sandwich from there as
someone who like who loves chicken even
specifically like I eat time the chicken
this is delicious right I would gladly
eat this every day of my life question
so what what's different about the
waffle they're like how do you
applesauce applesauce why that sounds
better anyway so you can just straight
up use applesauce instead of eggs and
why doesn't everyone do that and so much
more fluffier - oh my god what's that
over there
[Laughter]
waffle me I feel like you could describe
crossroads as like good food with
compassion just gonna say it I'm sorry I
would eat this over Roscoe's chicken and
waffles in a heartbeat vegetarian or
vegan or whatever you think they just
eat like rice and beans all day or like
bananas look at all this yeah it could
be more
[Music]